I know right this is already exactly
what you do yeah I love it what's up
everybody welcome back to the stage I'm
Greg Miller this is Freddie Wong yo and
that's Tim Gettys I this is this is a
gentleman right here getting guitar hero
playstation 4 his name's Ben got you
slide over here you can come on come on
bed have a seat man and sit down will
take your load off man come on I'll put
on a headset this is a game spot cross
kind of funny where we just roll with
the punches and do it out oh we want to
we're very lucky Freddie why are you
here I'm here I don't know why I'm here
now you're one of our best friend Eric
I'm a pickle bro we are recognized
training I represent the gherkins all
the way the gherkins across the United
States of America me rang we look like
the worst Saturday morning news team oh
and then I'm going to go to Millie's
quilt shop to see what's going on with
their breast cancer awareness foundation
ah Freddie yeah of course our famous you
when people think YouTube superstar they
think I've seen it when they think of
YouTube make it when they think YouTube
they think of you yeah but nah I know
but nothing by all the time we talking
about you I wasn't always I wasn't
always on YouTube though before that I
had an illustrious career being a
professional rhythm game player you did
it but that's true that's that's yeah
we've merged she together with guitar
here alive because you've got to play
guitar here alive and kill it cuz you're
amazing a guitar hero and YouTube do
amazing at YouTube and you're amazing at
are doing both that one was a step down
from my rhythm gaming career they're
asking us if this if the setting is
correct here because obvious it's 43 if
I can imagine it's supposed to be no no
reason I don't think so no can we think
I'm gonna work on that what is it just
the PlayStation you got to hit it and
say hey go wide screen hit it Benny I
don't know Ben don't let's take a look
we're like we're down here it's got an
effort he mode for uh we wanted to
really feel like the authentic adore
here you remember i think it's it's
probably the folsom scott that would be
my guess I think it's well here's the
thing right right anybody who knows
where them giving those that the
hardcore people have CRT tvs
absolutely minimize your leg right there
fighting game guys actually also do that
but i like to say that written out it's
not true rhythm game you guys are like
yeah we have to have the exact you know
to the middle of some fancy accuracy
first okay just go oh yes you have to
play there on the play i think still
kickin stings i think or is enough is
this idiot we're toying around with it
you're toying around it we're gonna do
it we're gonna do hi Freddie hey how's
it going Freddy whatever you two talk
about yeah is that like I said every
knows use YouTube famous freddie wong
and what I where did that go that went
to a dark place it went right to where I
must ago and if not right alright Jimmy
did you see me creeping up on the game
spot stage I just laid down there like
it was a therapy appointment see that I
was like here's my issue i have this guy
my last name what about you do i'm gonna
chuck it Scott's right behind me if I
sit he's checking cables he doesn't know
that I'm supporting him mentally Freddie
what I want to know is what's going on
right now with the career what's going
on with rocketjump so you know after I
think about a six-year hiatus from
rhythm gaming I've been doing movie
stuff we have a comic at rocketjump we
have videos right so we finish out being
in high school right now we literally
last week finished shooting a bunch of
shorts for showed up putting on hulu
later yeah we did we flipped buses we
ran horses is a big one we did a horse
race for the first which is like
filmmaker checklist is like do a horse
we need a horse right and we just don't
real quick didn't kill a horse good okay
only good like every morning we will
wake up like please don't worry you know
please no one get kicked in the head by
a horse please no horse break their leg
and then we have to kill it please don't
ended in horse get stuck in quicksand
cuz that happens to like your knee known
yet on you never know now I other three
right there though yeah well the crazy
about horses too is like they don't care
about anything train movie horses
they're like we're like hey can we do
this with this like they you can shoot a
gun next to them they won't care rock
all right the crazy thing about Freddie
Wong he has a story for everything no
matter what word you say he'll be like
oh let me tell you about horses will
this all you about the thing everyone is
that he knows everything I don't mean it
like the annoy like Nick Scarpino thinks
he knows that already actually no 7 as
interesting stories about those things
since I Wikipedia hooked up to my gosh
lend them up haha all right so have you
played this guitar here alive I've seen
it I haven't given this a shot yet uh
what's owning it I'm gonna bring the one
here we go gentlemen on stage bring you
more chicken we have mad gentlemen two
of them before you unfortunately are
coming off your your hair is amazing I
want you to know what happened gentlemen
let's come on up be careful in my ear
Kevin no no no why would you do that
hello gentle day I think it is yeah and
this young man how's it going man now
Jamie's beer and rivals mine and I don't
like that hey Greg how are you let's
scoot over Hill scoot over let's squeeze
all right do you guys go this is for you
to introduce yourselves i'm jamie
jackson i run freestyle games i'm crave
director and made this nice i am matt m
shadows from avenged sevenfold x 70 that
a shadows good lord and we are a part of
this game so we're here I decided yep
you're also a friend of kind of funny
yeah your friend I huh I'm a friend of
Mary's hung out don't worry I am all
right Freddie go tear something about
what are you playing here there's a shot
of the king for a day pierce the veil it
sees its worth 10 we're now thanks oh
did we not get sunk like I can't I sunk
ants are sunk tell you what Jamie bring
angel oh it's freaking out waste a III
we got you I do we get sunk if you pull
all the phone by the way you'll see that
it's about 40,000 wireless networks
within range of any given things so you
got we're gonna head and there we go we
have been sunk ladies and gentlemen
knowledge in shock now what's different
about guitar here alive ah this is a
load of things different first of all
the gameplay is different so we changed
all that buttons up so instead of having
those five buttons down your neck we've
now other six bones in two rows and you
know we weren't we felt like we needed
some new gameplay when we came back we
wanted to give you something new to
learn we didn't just like give you
something super easy I'm and then the
other thing is in a guitar when we said
two people woods what's it do for you in
the past they ones like makes me feel
like a rock star makes me feel like
these guys yeah so we were hopeful how
can we how can we take that one step
further so we went alright well let's
turn the camera around and let's make it
first person and then on top of that we
will all it needs to feel real so you're
doing a difficult one yeah i think
there's lag too
the hair of I like it so the nice thing
that's all right we filmed real people
and these people might have jumped
everybody in here we just dump them into
this there was no time he said oh I'm
gonna tell right so if there's no
calibration but you see it yeah but
we're seeing it or seen it all right
yeah you can't hear it either apparently
and you're also like you're sucking a
little bit at the moment which may not
be your folk haha Bay look at the
audience look at the audience reactive
for the audience no no I'm Freddie's
getting back on it I can't play guitar
and guitar hero I got I usually have to
be like a base or put it on easy or
medium so the fact that Freddie's
already doing better that's difficulty
than I do he's doing with no sound and
lag pretty goddamn impressive yeah I
remember a couple months back when you
guys first showed this game off in a San
Francisco with us I got to demo I mean
Alfredo to the let's play and I was like
I love guitar hair I got this sorry
playing and I was like wait can I switch
the difficulty on the fly and he's like
yeah you can I was like all right let's
go harder I go harder media like oh my
god this is too hard I can't wait to
like learn how to play this because it's
totally different man it's like with the
new play style with a black and white
keys man it's a you have to wrap your
mind around it yeah I mean we wanted to
make it a bit easier to play right at
that base level and so many people only
ever use three fingers when they play it
I remember telling you yep and and
that's why we went for three that the
three buttons put in two rows so like
top end you got a lot more difficulty a
lot more things to learn at better the
bottom end you've only got three buttons
you got a price is pretty
straightforward yep now you see usually
i would say stop the demo let's fix this
but I've got you for 12 minutes so right
now we're seeing the audience flip out
boo you cuz that's right yeah they come
here they hate that's it so basically
when you start this and when you're
getting it right and when it's playing
ball you know if you're hitting the
notes you're gonna stay the crowds going
to stay with you they're going to sing
back to you as well so which we kind of
we've done a 3d audio design inside it
so if you're near the front of the stage
and the crowd is singing back to you're
going to hear that come through the mix
a lot more if you're near the drums like
you run it over to now you're actually
going to hear the drums come through a
lot more as well but then if you start
to screw it up and you get it wrong and
you kind of lose the crowd then kind of
like this they're going to let you know
about it
so how hard was it to film this stuff
like how did you guys how many venues
are in here yeah where r I feel like
this was just like months of just going
around the world hanging out at the
coolest places faking rock hi everybody
they're doing really good now so
everybody cheered all right now they
suck boo but if we if that's what you
think then we convinced you really well
it was actually in a like a hanger in
deepest darkest England and it rains the
whole time Wow and this was all green
screen and we filmed it with a big giant
robot camera oh yeah it was pretty
insane this thing I always measure
things in size of dinosaurs okay good it
would be sooo yeah it was about a
velociraptor sighs yeah okay robot and
it would take your head off yeah the
video really impresses me man like the
way that it will segue between if people
are cheering and booing it looks really
good it's like seamless in a way that I
can rub my head back let's do stuff up
then things we like to think because of
the 15,000 wireless devices beaming
signals around the globe 33 is eating
your soul yeah yeah sure that's how bad
it wasn't better anyway took the guitar
fries sorry got to take it down look at
that I was here for one thing and I've
let you down yeah now yeah all right so
now hand me the PlayStation controller
and I'm gonna fiddle around and get at
hdmi-out m shadows how are you I'm great
how are you I'm great why did you guys
want to be a part of this game we want
to be a part of any type of music game
is promoting music and promoting new
artists and yeah I mean you look at the
few bands that are on here right now
it's you know he's playing pierce the
veil and these are all new artists that
are coming up and there's not many ways
to get your music out there anymore and
in terms of getting in front of a large
audience here sharit our hero just
really provides that for us no it always
has been like otário for me like I to
this day have artists on my ipod or
iphone that I never listened to until I
heard him in the games and now I love
them so someone did a poll on our
website like how did you hear about
Avenged Sevenfold and I'd say eighty
percent of it was either some sort of
video game or guitar hero yeah so or up
at noon when I interviewed you that one
time I mean that's that's probably um
it's also like a different way of expiry
racy music itself right it's all I cast
of anymore because normally when you
listen music so I was passive it's like
in the car or when you're jogging or
something bad and then for once you know
there's very few times when it's like
I'm gonna sit down actually listen to
something well you know when I was
growing up and there wasn't the internet
and there wasn't all these things i
would put a record in I had to get into
it I paid for it yeah with guitar hero
you're gonna have to learn these songs
you're gonna use to the songs and you're
gonna know I'm inside and out and you
you learn to love artists that way right
so it's really cool I definitely learned
an appreciation of Black Sabbath and
everything else war pigs and all these
other people and songs that popped up
and I've never heard before totally now
Freddie what I want to know as a rhythm
game expert and then retired to go make
these movies and that hasn't panned out
obvious retired on top by the way I left
that part out on top does this get you
excited like are you ready to jump back
into a guitar here yeah it does you know
and I think the big thing was when
people were talking about you know
what's the next level what's the next
evolution of it everyone was still
thinking and that sort of same mindset
of like okay well of course they're
gonna be the same guitar controllers
same sort of note highway what happy you
know and just the idea of like having
you know the parallelization one it's
like it's something that's new that
you're gonna have to learn so anyone
who's a veteran of its gonna have to
come back and so r e split their mind
and to it actually is a little bit more
authentic to hand shapes when your time
out you know guitar chords or a lot of
that stuff and that's sort of one of the
challenges I think from rhythm gaming in
general is like how do you make these
you know how do you make any given song
interesting yeah and a lot of it has to
do with your setup in terms of note
highway and you're set up in terms of
how you're playing it and having it be
this way also gives you a lot more
combinations to sort of interact with it
and then for me personally I don't know
see I I play piano growing up I kind of
got rid of stage fright by playing in
front of strangers like classical music
I think it's hilarious the idea of like
that because I know that some people
some people in our office they were
seeing the trial and they're like I
can't watch that trailer man it's like I
can't like its rights me out watching
this yeah I can't imagine that
experience you know that's what always
you can be away from really getting
crazy when I go play it at houses right
I'd be so worried and if I played on
anything other than medium first off if
I put it on medium everybody is that
like really man and
if you go up too hard and I start
missing it people get mad at ya know I
can't do that kind of pressure on top of
that now that we have the audience and
stuff I remember the first time I was
playing like when we walked out you saw
that there was a ton of people because
it felt like it was gonna be a smaller
bed night it was a real moment of like
oh man but there's pressure on me too i
actually do good and let me tell you
this as someone who's played a video
game in front of tens of people yes that
this very much accurately captures that
experience of performing in front of a
crowd feeling the booze so that's what
you've done guitar here alive you
brought our fears to let collective
anxiety has gone up by a measurable
factor as a result of this game I assume
but when you said stage all right if the
operator feels that that was I fixed it
um when you said stage fright that was
actually a little internal code word for
the project when we have in the
backcountry and that was our goal that's
awesome nail we got switched seats I
think you were closer so you're seeing
that there are you poker might the I we
got religion yes which to switch to the
farting right look at this oh my god
this is just like real easy is how it is
mr. shadows anything can happen yeah but
now my grammar was judging you hard what
they all tend to do that was the
prettiest when I heard that it was
coming back right you're sorry here's
Mack back guitar hero is gonna you know
come I sent Tim and Alfredo to go play
it I envisioned it being the guitar hero
I had already seen in like okay and that
was like alright it's cool that it's
back and then when you came back and
showed me the video you and Alfredo did
and then it's three and it's up and it's
down I mean it was like this is the one
I think I'm more interested in this than
ever yeah because this seems now that
it's back to being like not to knock any
other games but this is like the game of
skill now right of like actually trying
to go and do that i'm i'm here to
perfect these songs more exactly and
that's something that I'm always load
about guitar hero has been that our
Katie feel to it when you want to get a
new high score and you want to get
better at it you want to beat the songs
on higher difficulties and learn as you
go through like with the old ones having
to learn to do the three fingers than
the four then the moving like that took
steps you know it was a process i feel
like that's going to happen again with
this and excited have it's been way too
long since i've had that experience of
picking up the guitar and being like
well
new and fresh right right right right
right and and like that was important to
us when we made it you know thinking
about that game play like we knew we've
got our casual player and we knew
there's going to be a lot of people who
just want to come back to this that
never played it so we wanted to make it
super easy so just like three buttons a
basic level super easy but like you
picked up at the top end it's difficult
to master yeah we want our core fans to
come back and have to learn something
again we just came back with the same
game everyone would be acing it straight
away and there'd be no challenge so we
thought and a challenge is super
important and I don't have to change me
too much I get always the eyelid down I
know but that was always a thing I hated
people like Freddie and I pretty
favorite reasons now but the people who
it came to so naturally going through
and just being amazing a guitar hero mmm
i wish i could be there but i am I have
no rhythm so all right have you guys
have you guys seen GH TV yet as well yes
what's left for and where they play the
music videos in the back while you play
right yeah that's right so we're with
then when that a lot this e3 that's why
it's great to be here with Matt because
you know we're going to be having some
exclusive content from these guys right
at launch which we're still working
through but we're pretty stoked right
just sign the contract it's signed it's
done we're just trying to figure out
what songs we want to release first yeah
but it's going to be live footage from
some big concert so you've been playing
and so it's gonna be a real audience and
it's gonna be some some live stuff that
can be very exciting here's my thing for
you and the shadows is that what you
originally are your people you didn't
come to be yourself but when your people
reached out that you were you know
you're coming through you want to have
mine up at new and all stuff I was like
sure and then you came in and you were
totally into games right we kicked out
about Zelda for a long long time long
time that get i don't see any zelda
around here but i know right Tim oh my
god Freddie's [ __ ] killing it right
now that let me this point oh I'm sorry
everybody i forgot Freddie Wong Scott if
he gone congratulations ready oh yeah
slow clap great keep it to everyone go
to rocket Joe Zelda's right there zelda
triforce heroes no
my heroes Skyward Sword son but no the
fact that you were so in two games you
not I mean but you're also this crazy
awesome talented musician oh I always
talked about the fact that I need all
the old people in Congress to die
because when they do the new generation
will have grown up with games and it'll
be natural are you seeing that like when
you're on the road doing tours well
while you start talking to other
musicians who are into this as much as
you are that they like video games to
his video games everywhere a lot of the
biggest bands are in the video games and
yeah Jim route from slipknot always
playing games I mean all these bands
they're all in the games yeah that's
what we do on the bus that's what we do
backstage you know me I got my whole
gaming rig on venue to venue so I mean
yeah it's a different generation we grew
up with games when I was growing up
obviously the generation before me was
looked down on games a little bit like
it's a kid yeah I'm course of course and
then now all my friends still play games
and we're in our mid 30s so still then
here to stack do you feel like you know
you're talking about right now picking
the songs picking the footage does it
all carry more weight for you like you
want to make sure that because you know
how many times have you seen a game come
out that's like some license thing that
somebody put out and didn't really care
about well we wouldn't yeah we wouldn't
license our music to anything we didn't
feel is going to be top level yeah and
also the guy that does all the button
work I was talking to earlier and I was
like make sure it's he's like no it'll
be perfect guys because there are a lot
of musicians undergo this isn't that's
not right or that's not that notes not
doing that triplet or not sure all right
and that's the thing about these games
you got to make sure it's it's right for
the real musicians that know and that's
why we we work with Activision on a lot
of stuff because Activision has top-tier
you know companies that are making reg
form so then for you is that more
pressure like if we get the microphone
is that more pressure knowing that
you're bringing in now people who you
can't already be like that's not how I
hold the guitar there or no that's not
what I want to give you this yours like
sign the contract ah you know it's not
more pressure it's actually really
refreshing because you know we really
give a [ __ ] about our game so we want to
make sure it's the best content as well
so when we talked to Matt and they're
like it's got to be the best one and I
want it to I want to be really hard then
that's really refreshing for us because
it's like well great we can we can drive
push boundaries with it and like Matt
said you met Pete
who's a huge fan and he can't wait to do
the markup and you know he will not
sleep until it's perfect so yeah it's
definitely refreshing and it's fun to do
it that way so then what's next for
Guitar Hero live like have you revealed
everything there is a reveal do we know
what the game is or you still got stuff
up your sleeves so what we've revealed
is there's there's a bunch of songs that
we've been released in on tracklist
Tuesdays it's set over to festivals so
we're gonna have a festival in the UK
and a festival in the US and you know
we've made them up ourselves so the UK
one's called sound dial and the US has
called rock the block and they both
really embody kind of the festival scene
so the UK it's raining and there's mud
and wellies everywhere and then in the
u.s. it's a lot sunnier and everyone
looks a lot happier those are the real
$19 just like San Francisco we know it's
so well that's how it works so we
haven't done the full tracklisting yeah
but what we are stop telling people is
like you're going to play full sets with
these bands so and the band as you've
seen from the stuff date they we've
created them to look like they're gonna
play the music that you're playing so
it's about being authentic it's about
really putting you in putting you there
and you know we didn't want to build a
game which is about building advertise
of yourself we want you can wear
whatever you want in your living room
and play this game you want to do it in
your undies that's fine I will I know
you were gonna be good or are sometimes
nothing at all exactly exactly so we're
done that and then now the big the big
reveal for us now is GH TV and diving
into that and showing people what we can
do and then they could say some of their
kind of you know the on-demand show
stuff work where Matt stuff's going to
go in and all the different prizes and
all the different things and there's
there's a lot of info so I mean if you
get time come by the stand cuz I could
take an hour I wouldn't have explained
it all I don't want all your pre canned
responses Freddie Wong yes playing under
some of the worst conditions possible
for the game how was it it's fun you
just use own into it and it just becomes
like a thing where you're just you're
reacting sort of moment to moment you
know you like the black and white keys
then being on top of each other I do
because again like you're doing chord
shapes sculpt well like rough guitar
chord here so you know sort of on that
so it actually starts to feel a little
bit more than just sort of sliding up
and down with this or the old method
that red
right yeah no I dig it man and you know
I think again it's about it's about
interacting with music in a different
way and try and find a different way of
like connecting with it that's just that
goes beyond just sort of passively
listening and that and anything that
gets more people understanding of
difference or components of music you
know I think I'm all for that mmm Tim
yes are you ready for Guitar Hero my god
I'm so ready for this are we gonna do a
lens place yeah we are okay we're gonna
do a lot of them it's gonna be a lot of
parties yeah all the parties do we
normally have Greg well I was unhappy
part number too busy generalize parties
I'm down okay we do it m shadows will
you come to our guitar hero live parties
good fun's fun I like having you guys
here now now we we talked a lot about
guitar hero Freddie yeah tell me more
about your Hulu show oh yeah no I'm
shadows all about the Hulu show yeah you
ask questions about this movie about it
hahaha so we're doing we're doing these
we're doing these eight shorts and we're
sort of building a show around what we
what sort of it's like to because have
his new media company making videos and
having a whole bunch of people sort of
rely on us you know to make a living so
to speak but we're mate we're doing
ridiculous stuff we were like I said we
flipped we flipped a truck and a bus
that's fine because we're talking my
school bus on purpose I'm purpose okay
when we talking about school bus or
they're like hey i like how hard is it
to flip a school bus like it's extremely
difficult to flip a school bus right
well that's but it if you just like
because they design school buses to not
flip we think i was like yeah it's
actually a good thing because normally
there's kids in there yeah no buses are
so safe they don't need seatbelts well
the well the funny thing is like these
stunts guys they have the math that they
do to flip these things that you would
expect like all kinds of calculations
and like okay wait and force and
velocity Newton's other they're like
okay well it takes one of these ratchets
to flip the truck and a school bus ways
like twice as much so we'll use to
ratchets right that's it that's all
you're doing math why it's like yeah it
should be ok right all right okay that's
the level of a map that you need to know
if I flip buses in the film and
destroyed good I have a question for you
Freddie yeah what's up who wrote this
show this is a mix of people we actually
have a lot of a lot of our friends
who are coming from video game high
school we're helping out we also brought
on Anthony Burch who was former Parmalee
over at borderlands as well as a sh Lee
birch and Ashley's also directing yes as
well showing up in a couple of these as
well but it was like one of those cool
like group dynamic and it was great to
have like all these sort of different
writer points of views and each sketch
is the kind of amalgamation of
everyone's kind of sense of humor and
ice a little I think it's very unique
and I hopefully something that people
don't necessarily expect like the scale
of these sketches are bigger than
anything you've ever seen before that
from from what we're going for like each
one what kind of trying to do sort of
try and hit like sort of blockbuster
movie production value they on when do
they come on so we're aiming later on
this year it's going to be available on
Hulu as well as the shorts will be
available on youtube.com slash nice so
rocketjump guitar here alive Avenged
Sevenfold kind of funny we're going to a
commercial and they come back with tony
hawk